this is a production of Cornell
University
and thanks Don for inviting me and for
you all for coming and also thanks for
your contributions to capacity we're
really excited Don's going to be
teaching an online course he's had
several grad students helping him and
also it's in collaboration which to talk
chicago botanic gardens and american
public Gardening Association so that'll
be in starting in February right January
Jan right ok great so like probably a
lot of you in this room I actually think
quite a bit about climate change and I
really like winter and cold weather so I
always feel you know kind of sad when we
have those flushing events or what we
call indicating events in the winter I'd
rather see snow but I hadn't really done
much about climate change education
professionally for a long time and i
kind of consider myself almost as a
climate change denier and not like a
denier and that i don't believe that
climate change is occurring but a denier
in that I kept wishing that it would go
away and that somebody else would would
you know help solve would solve the
problem I wouldn't have to worry about
it but when Hurricane sandy occurred a
couple years ago and i was in ithaca so
i wasn't down in new york city but the
images and thinking about people i knew
going through this some of you know
Gretchen farrens who recently retired
from Cornell Cooperative Extension she
was in Far Rockaway he's just taking the
brunt of the storm and then the media
attention really made me sort of think
about climate change education I think
in a way it was a tipping point for me
in terms of my profession and especially
since it's Don mentioned I direct EPA's
national environmental education
training program it's a large
cooperative agreement with EPA five
years 11 million dollars and so I felt
like as a leader in the field I really
needed to take more responsibility than
I was taking and so my presentation
today is a sort of about my search for
what we should do in terms of the field
of environmental education and how we
should be addressing climate change
education because I don't know all the
answers but
I'll be talking about several projects
that are helping me to find the answers
and we should have time plenty of time
for discussion at the end so I'm hoping
that some of these ideas will generate
some discussion okay so you know you saw
the images really kind of disturbing
scary do you need to turn down the
lights a little bit that would help it's
all the way in the back anyway East
thirty-fourth Street the Midtown Tunnel
okay looks good thank you and then there
was as you know a lot of media attention
to climate change as a result of
hurricane sandy and especially Bloomberg
i think it was is really a leader in
taking action in terms of mayors
nationally and internationally so you
kind of knew that people are going to
rebuild they're going to restore sites
like this community garden before it
restored after and then after it was
restored so this is immediately after
Hurricane sandy but we didn't really
know how they'd rebuild in is if the
sort of event would make them rebuild in
different ways if they would adapt and
think about things differently as a
result of this major event and I'm
particularly interested since I'm an
environmental education about interested
in the learning opportunities that occur
through community gardening or through
another stewardship or civic ecology
practice like this one which is doing
restoration after Hurricane sandy so
people are planting doing grasses to try
and read or restore the dunes to protect
from high water events but before I talk
about hurricane sandy and how people
reacted in particular environmental
educators I wanted to give you a quick
primer on environmental education for
those of you who aren't familiar with
the field and basically environmental
education is about increasing knowledge
and attitudes about the environment but
it's also about increasing people's
ability to make informed decisions and
take responsible action so as a
land-grant University we do a lot of
science education and we kind of think
of our mission as extending the
science-based knowledge to the people of
the state and beyond so we more stick to
science knowledge and environmental
education also incorporates science
knowledge we do a lot of environmental
sciences education so to speak but we
add on civic engagement and it's also a
very normative River values-driven field
so we're doing this for a purpose and
that is to hopefully encourage
environmental responsible behaviors and
then increase Environmental Quality so I
think that's a bit different from
science education per se but there's a
couple of problems with environmental
education and I think this one also
applies to science education and so that
that is that basically knowledge even
though we assume that say people know
more about climate change then they'll
act according to the ways we'd like them
to act so but now it's doesn't
necessarily lead to action so these two
figures are taken from a paper by dan
kane who's at Yale University and so if
you look at this first one on the y axis
you have climate science intelligence so
how much they know how many correct
responses they get on a survey or a test
of about climate science and if you look
across here it's people's positions on
global warming so whether you believe
your position is that there's no warming
occurring warming is naturally caused or
warming is human induced doesn't have
any correlation with how much you know
about climate science and if you can see
this bottom graph here it kind of
explains what does determine our
positions on climate change so how much
you [ __ ] global warming is a risk
whether it's extremely high risk or not
a risk at all has a whole lot to do with
whether you identify yourself as a very
liberal strong Democrat or a very
conservative strong Republican all right
so it has less to do they've actually
has some other graphs in this paper that
showed that the Republicans may have
just as much knowledge as the Democrats
but how they react is
determined by our identity essentially
what political identity that we assume
and a number another problem with
knowledge assumption that knowledge
leads to action can be viewed through
this lens of terror management theory I
don't know how many of you know my
colleague Janice Dickinson she wrote a
paper in 2009 it's an ecology and
society and she synthesized a whole
bunch of empirical studies about that
are you going through the leg using the
lens of terror management theory and
then she applied that to how we think
about or how we react to climate change
so the whole idea here is that if I were
to tell you that global warming is
occurring it's a disaster you know we're
not going to be able to produce that the
crops we're producing in New York State
we're going to have droughts we're going
to have flooding and what's more going
to have diseases and it's going to be
total devastation then I might make you
feel vulnerable so what you want to do
is then make yourself feel invincible
less vulnerable when we see this with I
apologize this a little sexist but you
know guys when they get to sort of be
the midlife crisis they like to buy SUVs
or trucks or nice little sport card
convertibles that they might be filling
an age little age-related vulnerability
and they want to be invincible well when
Sarah Palin and her colleagues or her
supporters you know they were getting
sort of bombarded by sort of drilling in
Alaska and environmentalists well they
really made themselves feel really
strong and invincible by talking about
drill baby drill and I don't know how
many of you can see this guy here but he
looks a lot to me like Vladimir Putin
and we all know how close rushes to
Alaska so maybe he was there and they'd
probably believes in drill baby drill
too so but the idea is this terror
management theory is that we might have
reactions unintended or people might
have reactions that we didn't intend
when we tell them how bad things are
because they want to make themselves
feel less vulnerable
okay so another problem with
environmental education is that the type
of action that environmental education
often not always but often sort of tries
to foster is individual behaviors
usually not always but it's often like
okay reduce sweater while you're taking
a shower while you're brushing your
teeth walk to work instead of drive to
work and when you consider the scale and
the magnitude is sort of the timing that
it's here already global warming as well
as the magnitude of the issue I think
there's a bit of a scale mismatch in
some of the behaviors that we promote
and what's needed and then also the idea
of mitigation versus adaptation so
environmental education has almost
totally been focused on mitigating our
impact on global warming right so we're
reducing our energy use we're reducing
our use of plastics for example we're
recycling so we're trying to mitigate
human impact on climate change or on the
environment but given what we know about
climate change that is already here I
think the field really needs to think
about adaptation and this is one of the
reasons I avoided this for a long time
is because for adaptations almost like
you're being a turncoat if you're an
environmental educator you're sort of
giving up the fight because you're also
saying that you know we're not just
going to try to conserve what we have
we're also going to face reality and
adapt to what's already happening so
just in summary three issues that I
think face our field of environmental
education and are why we need to think
about changes in our practice of
environmental education or in our
discipline and they are that knowledge
doesn't necessarily lead to behavior
change scale mismatch of the actions
that we foster or promote versus what's
occurring with global warming and then
the need to consider adaptation okay
so but I don't really know how we should
change so one of the things that I did I
like to think of it as crowdsourcing
there's three projects that I'll discuss
today that we're using to help us figure
out how our field might evolve or change
and the first one is actually research
project where we looked at New York City
environmental educators who experience
sandy and then I'm going to talk about a
really an outreach or extension type
project climate change environmental
education fellows and then we also
convened a panel of national experts in
global warming and environmental
education to help us understand what
they thought the field should be doing
okay so the first one we looked at New
York City environmental educators after
sandy and the question we asked was how
did their programs respond to the event
to the superstorm and out of a sample of
over I think it's about 2,000
environmental stewardship organizations
in New York City and these have been
documented and mapped by the u.s. Forest
Service urban the old station urban
research station in the city and they
include everything from you know major
sort of policy organizations to these
small-scale community gardens so that's
why there's a lot and we took a sample
of 45 that we thought it was a
purposeful sample that we thought were
most likely to be engaged in
environmental education and we
interviewed them open-ended interviews
conducted site visits and then analyzed
these open-ended responses to look at
what themes might come out and I should
say that the majority of this work was
conducted by a person who works for me
in New York City and his name's Bryce du
Bois
okay so we found two kinds of changes
one was in the program's actual
environmental education programs that
people were conducting and the other was
in that organizations that were doing
these programs and I'm just going to
talk about the first the program changes
and there were three that emerged
through these interviews one was that
organizations or programs were
reinforcing existing content second was
that they were conducting new types of
stewardship or restoration activities
and the third was that they were
incorporating this notion of resilience
quite a bit into their programs so an
example of reinforcing existing
activities green map is an organization
in New York City and they map green
spaces green places around the city so
that people they want to visit a
community garden or they want to go to a
high line by line park or they want to
go to another small or large park they
can kind of know where these green
spaces are and after Hurricane sandy
they simply imposed places that were
impacted by Hurricane sandy on their
maps and also thought of them as
opportunities where they might restore
some of this green space so this sort of
idea of really reinforcing what you're
already doing was quite common and I
think another example is a school and
then it was in Queens and they've been
teaching about energy for water
resources and they simply used hurricane
sandy then as examples for what they'd
already been teaching about because kids
were very aware of energy since their
energy was cut off sometimes for several
weeks
so a second type of change was new
environmental stewardship activities
this one's with a breezy point green
committee and again for those of you who
know Gretchen farrens this is her
neighborhood in the Rockaways and she
was a leader this activity and I showed
another slide earlier but the idea of
trying to restore dunes to reduce the
impact of future high water events and
we weren't really surprised that people
were engaging in these stewardship
activities not just because they think
it can protect them against a future
event but because our past research and
this is keys tidball in my lab and
myself we've seen over and over again
how after a disaster or during times of
conflict people often turn to gardening
and other forms of greening as a
response and it's more sort of their
individual psychological resilience in a
lot of cases although they may also say
it's going to bring their neighborhood
or their ecosystem back so just as other
examples after 911 we saw a lot of
Memorial Gardens sort of spontaneously
created it might take a median strip and
plant there or take a community garden
and add some daffodils to it as a
memorial garden and Keith worked a lot
after Hurricane Katrina in New Orleans
and he found a lot of tree planting and
tree care which is consistent with New
Orleans and the idea of the live oaks
and how important they are the identity
of the city and as Don mentioned we
captured all that in this examples
really from around the world we have
this is an edited volume but we have
somebody from Berlin who talked about
the greening of the Berlin Wall after
the fall of communism so there's lots
and lots of examples of this greening in
what we call red zones
so the third have change was this
incorporation of resilience and
resilience speak into these programs and
these are a couple examples up rose is a
community organization in Brooklyn and
they created a climate justice community
resilience center and then green map or
excuse me growing New York City they
created this resilient New York City
community gardening guide so it's how
people can address issues like salt
water in addition of their soils and
trees falling in the mill their gardens
and so forth and it's probably not
surprising that people are using this
term resilience because Bloomberg
actually created this new resilience
guide as part of plan New York City
which well he's no longer the as mayor
but was his sustainability plan for the
city but also this term resilience is
really popping up everywhere and I i
think that people often don't know what
they're referring to because it's such a
the term has so many different meanings
there's individual or psychological
resilience there's ecological resilience
there's engineering resilience and
there's social ecological systems
resilience just to name a few and so
Bryce Dubois and I now we're following
up with some of these groups in New York
City to determine what they really mean
by resilience and I was in New York City
giving a talk of last Friday and
somebody said that the term resilience
is very resilient and then we had a
resilience workshop last friday at the D
so she put on a man library and somebody
said the same thing so but just to show
you how much this term is catching on I
was reading the journal our own Ithaca
journal this morning Oh actually it's
USA today at the khajur no but anyways
and they say Hoboken New Jersey Paul
finds that neighborhood neighbor Lina's
matters neighbor helping neighbor trust
in a community looking out for each
other an Associated Press n 0 RC Center
for Public Affairs research survey
suggests that those factors collectively
termed social resilience
have a big impact on how prepared
communities feel for disasters such as
superstorm sandy thirty-seven percent of
residents in areas reporting high levels
of neighbors helping each other are very
or extremely confident their
neighborhood would recover quickly from
a disaster compared to twenty two
percent in areas with lower levels of
neighborhood neighborly cooperation I
think they probably would have called
this social capital or social
connections or something else a few
years ago but now it's becoming social
resilience okay so my question that I
addressed in this part of the talk was
whether hurricane sandy was really a
tipping point for environmental
education and environmental educators in
New York City and sort of whether it
stretched the limits of what they were
doing and they went over sort of broke
with what they were doing in the past
and i would say that there's the answers
probably know there were a bunch of
small innovations but it wasn't as I
sort of maybe hope for that they came up
with all the solutions of how we should
address global warming in environmental
education so I'm going to turn to the
next project and this is a project
that's part of that national
environmental education training program
that Don mentioned and we have a fellows
program they're called community climate
change fellows and what we did we have
26 people they were selected from a
group from across the country and in
Mexico and Canada and we did a workshop
with them for a week they came together
and as a result of this workshop and the
resources were putting into them they're
supposed to do some local community
climate change interventions and so
again we're kind of looking for what are
these practitioners in the field come up
with and what can we learn from them so
what I want to do now is share with you
here's just some of the fellows as I
mentioned we have 26 but I wanted to
share with you a couple of the projects
they came up with so this one's by Jason
Davis and he's in Boston he's actually a
musician and he came up with this idea
of recording climate change stories and
I want to play one
for you and I want to ask you to think
about whether this story feels impactful
to you about you know how you think
about climate change and whether it
might move you or maybe even make you
think differently or want to do
something differently my name is Fred
small I'm the senior minister at first
parish in Cambridge Massachusetts
Unitarian Universalist one of the
special places to me is the coast of
Maine where my wife's family is had a
place for generations I'm Penobscot Bay
my wife and I've KY act all along the
Maine coast and off Nova Scotia I grew
up in New Jersey which is not that
dissimilar climate and I'm a Four
Seasons guy it's the changing of the
seasons that that excites me there's
something about that that cycle of
seasons that is very nourishing to make
reading go McKibben's book the end of
nature in 1989 was painful for me and
many of us I think it just began a
decade's a long season of grief so that
what might have been a beautiful
sometimes called Indian summer day just
a kind of gift like wow you know it's
what a beautiful day it's so warm and
pleasant you're in october or november
or december then becomes a woman
something disturbing my daughter is 11
and she's already said that she wished
she had been born earlier because she
doesn't look forward to what is in store
for her and her generation and as a
parent you know that that breaks my
heart to hear bad things are going to
happen but bad things have happened
before human history very very bad
things
the great playing in Europe low-cost
slavery you know all kinds of suffering
some if you will natural some
perpetrated by human depravity that
isn't to minimize it but to say that we
do have the capacity to get through this
but what I think is crucial is that
we've got to do it with with love and
not lose our spiritual center or our
moral compass as we go so for me as a as
a religious leader the question is not
are we going to win or are we going to
lose because in a sense we've already
lost we've lost tremendous amounts of
people species and good things that we
will not be able to recover and I think
it's going to get worse so the question
is not winning or losing but if you will
how we play the game do we stay loving
do we stay compassionate to treat each
other well do we treat our enemy as well
do we love our enemies as Jesus
challenge just to do
so you could good oops sorry about that
unless you all want to hear some more
but you can see that he has a bunch of
he's he's recorded a bunch of these
climate change stories from people in in
the US and Canada there was one from
Poland and you can go on to his website
and listen to others if you think that
they're worthwhile and then I wanted to
play you this 12 minutes 22 seconds one
of our climate change fellows Maria
talero just made a video of herself it's
kind of pieces of different lectures and
she covers a lot of the points that I
think are important so I wanted to show
that one also
so this is a difficult topic the topic
of climate change and maybe more
specifically global warming but it's
also a difficult topic because if you
think about it there's no place to go to
work on not the science to work on you
know these human questions of how can I
relate to this every workshop that I do
is is tailored for the group that I'm
presenting to but I want us to work
together to expand our concept of what
it means to be a climate change activist
to traditional presentations I would now
bombard you with you know the worst news
imaginable and you would think oh my god
I wish I hadn't come here this morning
how much weight do do the people you're
trying to reach give to what scientists
have to say what role does that play in
their life I think we often operate
under the assumption that everybody's
ready to hear through the scientific
channel maybe there's a part of you that
wants to just kind of reach in and do
something and do something on you know
the scale appropriate to the size of the
problem business as usual is built into
the very way we perceive the world
around us our social work spaces show us
the world as a place where we should
preserve and maintain our personal
status quo if we can change our social
work spaces we can change our perception
of reality and when we change our
perception of reality our actions will
change we need urgently to let go of the
idea that it's the stressed over
scheduled individual in each of us who
needs to wake up sudden will handedly
activate her moral conscience step up
and take action instead we need to look
at the social work spaces we're already
sharing with others and ask what kind of
potential is there here for transforming
them what would it take for you to join
a nonviolent resistance movement on
climate change there is no easy solution
but there is something we can do and I
want to argue that that's something we
can do is join the movement
help create a powerful grassroots
movement that moves the needle okay so
those are just two of our fellows Jason
Davis and Maria talero and each one as I
mentioned is doing a different project
and if you're interested more I could
share with you some of the other
projects they're doing there we go so so
to conclude this is the second project
is you know the question is what is the
impact of each of these individual
projects and is there a way really we
can make a larger project through the
group of fellows along with our staff on
the EE capacity project and we have lots
of other collaborators across the
country I found that those both those
both the video in the end the audio
we're very impactful but whether it
makes an impact at sort of a larger
level I think is a question ok so now
I'm going to go to the third and the
final project and that is that we
convened a panel of national experts and
we asked them to address the question is
environmental education that focuses on
small individual actions appropriate
given the scale of climate change so
here are experts we had John Kerry who
is a freelance environmental journalist
John Fraser who's an environmental ad in
science head researcher in new york city
life works nationally Kerry Fulton who's
with the environmental justice climate
change initiative in Washington DC and
Caroline Lewis who I think a number of
you know I don't know if anybody knows
her besides down but she weren't used to
work at Fairchild botanic garden and now
in Miami and now she started her own
organization climate leadership
engagement opportunities are Cleo again
operating in Miami which is ground zero
as you probably know climate change and
the sort of the mix of very conservative
politics and people who are addressing
climate change daily and in fact the
mayor of South Miami a bunch because
Miami has all these little cities that
are sort of part of the larger
metropolitan he's trying he there's a
movement down there for them to secede
from the state of Florida because the
people in northern Florida don't believe
in climate change but they see it in
their everyday lives with all the
flooding and hot
I mean my daughter lives there so I know
on our way to work she's off and walking
through water and then Billy Spitzer
from the New England Aquarium and
there's I think there's five themes that
came out of this workshop and I should
mention there were about 90 people from
New York City environmental educators
and related professionals so this came
out of the discussions amongst the
experts and with the people who
participated and the first is about
emotion and that environmental education
should really be considering how we help
people cope with emotions and these
emotions can be the sort of feelings of
vulnerability and climate change denial
that I discussed earlier when I
mentioned quite Tara management theory
but they can also be these feelings of
sadness and loss I think as the minister
in that video in the audio talked about
and it's really hard when you think
about you know are you just telling say
young people about the science of
climate change and what's going to
happen and then you have to sort of what
do you do about how they react to this
so the second is environmental justice
and I find this one really interesting
not only because it's sort of about a
movement and that there's already an
environmental justice movement and that
we can join forces with them and then
maybe have a larger impact but it's also
really interesting because i think the
civil rights movement has something has
possibly some lessons for us in dealing
with climate change so you know i mean
you can imagine what a sort of
overwhelming problem civil rights or
racial inequities word to people in the
60s and 50s and yet there was a really
well-organized for starting at the
grassroots movements that made
incredible changes in our society so
there may be things we can learn about
how they organized and how they worked
okay third is collective action and this
is the idea that we need to think about
not just these individual behavior
changes that we've thought about in the
past like you know changing our water
use a home level but also more
collectively how we can make a change in
Moorea talero really spoke about that in
the video I think that if we're going to
do think about collected to action when
things we might do is think about what
the research
is largely coming out of sociology that
talks about what are the elements that
are usually present before collective
action occurs and one of them is social
capital or trust and connections between
people as well as social norms so
instead of sort of starting an
environment led program with what is you
know climate change and global warming
you might start a program with thinking
about well how do we create some social
connections and trust amongst the people
and how do we create strong social norms
and then the theory would predict that
people have more capacity to act
collectively to address these issues
advocacy education and this one is
really the most controversial so it's
not just controversial for science
educators it's also really controversial
for environmental educators and part
because the field has been criticized
extensively for being advocates than
being you know left-wing socialists
communists whatever and so the reaction
has been to really retreat from any of
this normative stuff and just say well
we're going to teach the facts and then
we're going to help people to make their
own decisions and yet I think given the
scale again at the problem I think we
should reconsider this and again I think
we can look back at the civil rights
movement so think about us as a
land-grant institution and think about
the 50s or 60s and you know we would
think well our role is to do and it's
too bad Scott Peters isn't here because
he would have a lot to say about this
but our role is justice is to sort of
you know transfer what's known about
race or something like that based on the
science and if you look back on it now
we might say that would have been quite
irresponsible or even immoral so is
there a parallel here with climate
change
and then the last its climate changes in
the new normal I talked about that
earlier explicitly acknowledged and we
can't really conserve our natural
heritage at least in many cases as we
might have tried to do before so I said
I'd present three different projects but
I'm going to do a little bit more in
depth on this last project in particular
I want to talk about adaptation in
relation to climate changes the new
normal so climate change simply means
adjustments in ecological social or
excuse me climate adaptation means
adjustments in ecological social or
economic systems in response to climate
change and if you look at the IPCC
report that just came out this year they
have three different major categories of
adaptation options so there's physical
structural social which has to do with
equity issues and then institutional
which has to do with changing government
agencies or nonprofits or international
organizations but within each of those
categories they have sub categories that
I think and I've just chosen the ones
that I think are most consistent with
environmental education so
ecosystem-based under physical
structural community-based and education
under social and engagement under
institutional by the way this I just
picked up last night I think it was on a
BBC article and it's about but it's
Boston re-envisioning itself as Venice
so this is actually yeah they mentioned
Amsterdam also
okay so ecosystem-based adaptation is
the use of biodiversity and ecosystem
services to help communities than people
adapt to climate change and so we can
think of again this falls under physical
structural so we can think of sea walls
or putting all our you know utilities on
the second floor of buildings where
they're on flood zones or high water
zones but we can also think about
plantings oyster reefs oyster
restoration is a huge effort on our
restoration in New York City estuary
right now is sort of more consistent
with the environmental values of
environmental education and community
based adaptation turn locally driven
adaptation strategies that operate on
learning by doing bottom-up and
empowerment paradigm and here I like to
think of community gardens as a really
good example of a community-based
adaptation and the reason is because I
think people in community gardens they
engage in these kinds of discussions as
Megan knows and this helped them with
and they have to make a lot of decisions
right so they have to decide okay how do
we decide who gets a plot how do we
decide on whether pesticides are allowed
and if somebody lets their weeds grow
what kind of sanctions are we going to
have and there's been some work done by
Erika svensson in New York City at that
Forest Service Urban Research Station
looking at how what goes on this
decision making in these little bit
little kind of interventions and the
powerman that people get how it scales
up so these are I'd like to think of
these as kind of training grounds and a
lot of times the people that are in
community gardens are immigrants and
they may not have participated in civil
society previously and then you know
sometimes people that have been in these
gardens and Ben decision-making roles or
participated in these discussions then
go on and they become advocates at a
larger scale like for preserving green
space in New York City
so I think that there's a lot of these
kinds of civic ecology practices or
greening practices that we can think of
as combining ecosystem-based
community-based and education adaptation
in other words they provide
opportunities for Environmental Learning
even though there night not be a formal
education program there and these can be
things like restoring wetlands and salt
marshes to buffer against sea level rise
and installing green infrastructure such
as this green roof garden in new york
city as well as porous pavements and
community gardens so getting back to my
original question was super storm sandy
a tipping point for environmental
education probably not but i do think
that there is a lot of new ideas being
generated that we can follow up on and
so we are seeing changes in EE and some
of the major changes i think worth it
seeing are the use of the term
resilience and people starting to think
about adaptation these environmental
stewardship like the dune restoration
practices more thinking about collective
action and then reconsidering the notion
of advocacy given the scale of the
issues so with that I'd like to thank my
colleagues Bryce Du Bois Judy browse and
Ferguson and John Fraser who have helped
me think about some of these issues as
well as my funders but because I talked
about advocacy views expressed or not
necessarily those of the funding
agencies so if you're so much memory
thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu